So here we are in our swift extension to
UI view controller, and you'll need to
import mobile core services at the top
of the file like I've done here, and
this is where we're going to write
our launch video camera method.
Let's look back at the objective
C launch camera method, and
see what we need to include here.
Okay, I think I'm just going to make
a list of what this method is doing.
Create imagePicker,
set the properties of the image picker,
what properties are we setting?
Source type, media types,
allows editing,
and then set the delegate, and
then present the controller.
I think that's pretty much
all this method does, cool.
Now we'll copy these notes
over to the swift project, so
we can fill in that method.
Let's see what should we call
it recordVideoController,
set the source type which
is of course camera.
Media types is a little bit tricky,
because it has to be in array, and
also has to be a string, for now we're
going to set allows editing to false,
but we're going to change that later,
we set the delegate to self,
and we're almost ready.
Present, what's going on there,
cannot assign value of
type UIViewController to.
We need to conform to
the protocol of course, and
also the navigationController delegate.
Okay, cool, so that error went away.
And then we present it.
Probably don't really
need these comments now.
That I do it for
presenting the camera, and
now we also need to write the methods
to retrieve the video that we record.
Remember there are two methods that
we need to implement that are part
of the image picker control,
or delegate protocol
did finish picking media with info,
and imagePickerController did cancel.
So let's look back again at
the Objective C version, and
see how these methods
are implemented there.
Here we are in the Objective C project,
and
we're at the pragma mark for
ImagePickerControllerDelegate Methods.
If we look here in the method
didFinishPickingMediaWithInfo,
we can see that first,
we need to check the media type.
Then, if the media type is a movie,
we need to save this raw video URL.
And then here, the comments say get
start, and end points for a trim video.
Well we're not trimming the video yet,
so we can skip that part, and then here,
it's gotta call to crop video to square,
we're not cropping the video yet either.
I'll tell you what, for now, we'll just
save this video to the photos album
that way we'll know the recording
functionality is working.
So we're back in the Swift version of
our UI view controller extension, and
to make this file a little more
readable, I went ahead, and moved
to the image picker controller delegate
methods into an additional extension.
Here in the method did finish
picking media with info
is where we want to save our
video to the photo album.
So we'll call the method
UISaveVideoAtPath to save
to photos album, and we'll remember to
dismiss this view controller the image
picker controller,
this has to be a path.
And, if we scroll up to our launch video
camera method you can see that it's been
connected to storyboard,
it's connected to the record button.
So our launch video camera method is
ready, our image picker controller
delegate methods are ready, so
let's run it, and see how it looks.
Okay, now keep in mind that when I show
you these representations of the phone
on the screen.
I'm actually showing you a movie that
I recorded of me running the app on my
phone, because of course you're going to
need to be running the app on device,
if you're testing anything
involving the camera,
you won't be able to use the simulator.
Here you can see I can launch the
camera, I took a video of my teammate,
the cameras dismissed, and here you can
see that when I go out of the app, and
then I go into my photo library
my video is there, fantastic.